our next speaker is making his first
appearance at a Hillsdale event though
we have long been admirers of his from
afar we're delighted that he's able to
be here with his wife Julie thank you
for coming David a Clark jr. is the
sheriff of Milwaukee County Wisconsin
prior to becoming sheriff he had a long
and distinguished law-enforcement career
in the Milwaukee Police Department
beginning as a patrol officer he became
a detective and then joined the Homicide
Division where he did impressive work it
turns out he's really good at catching
felons and murderers and we thank you
for that because he was so good at what
he did he continued to be promoted to
lots of high level positions and then in
November of 2002 he was elected to his
first four-year term as sheriff winning
almost 2/3 of the vote in the most
recent election in 2014 almost 80
percent of voters pulled the lever for
him which tells me that law-abiding
citizens like it when criminals end up
in jail a summa [ __ ] laude graduate of
Concordia University in Wisconsin he is
also a graduate graduate of the FBI
National Academy in Quantico Virginia
and the recipient of a master's degree
in security studies from the US Naval
Postgraduate School so this is an
impressive list of accomplishments and
accolades to be sure but I have to tell
you as a fellow hoopster there was
another item on his bio that really
stood out which I have to mention he was
a member of the 1973 Marquette
University high school varsity
basketball team that won the state
private school championship so I think
that's that's quite impressive
please welcome to the podium sheriff
Clark
thank you so much
for that wonderful introduction that did
that for my wife that's a little inside
joke that goes back to our church we go
on Sunday and everybody that takes these
are directional mics but everybody that
takes the podium at church first thing
they do is bring these down and I always
say why does everybody bring them
microphones down when they get up there
so I did this I did this for her anyway
Wow this is amazing it really is to see
so many of you let me start with a
couple of ground rules first of all I've
come a long way I get invited all over
the country now to speak on some very
important issues and I have many of you
seen me on TV as a matter of fact
sometimes I think that's my real name is
that guy from TV so a lot of people in
store you know introduce him so hey
you're that guy on TV so now every once
in a while my wife at home she'll be
David David and she doesn't get any
response she comes on didn't you hear me
and I said no she said I've been yelling
David at the top of the stairs I said oh
you should have just said you're that
guy from TV even you would have got my
attention but anyway I've been across
this country met a lot of great people
and Hillsdale College reached out to me
a year ago April and invited me to come
and speak at this conference I had heard
of Hillsdale College I know it was in
Michigan I knew it's lean conservative
probably more than liens but outside of
that I didn't know too much about it but
I did and I said yes sure I'd like to do
that and then I heard it was gonna be in
New York I said well why is it in New
York I said that schools in Michigan and
my executive assistant said I don't know
it's in New York and it's at the Waldorf
Astoria I said you better call and tell
them yesterday but I want to thank
Hillsdale College for standing true to
your principles okay and and staying
this institution of higher learning of
academic rigor challenging your students
to be curious making it okay for them to
dissent to ask questions to challenge
prevailing orthodoxies unfortunately
unlike many of our colleges and
universities today which are nothing
more than laboratories of liberal
indoctrination and I think that we're
doing a disservice to the generations
coming after us because they won't be
able to critically think they'll be good
at being told what to do what to think
how to think how to say it what to
believe in you get a robot to do that
and you just program it with our
technological capability now but it's
dr. iron indicated we're human beings
and we didn't get this country to where
it's at today except for the fact that
people dream big that people challenged
prevailing orthodoxy remember at one
time we thought the world was flat
somebody had to come along and challenge
that remember the ridicule they were
made a laughingstock what do you mean a
new world you'll fall off the edge of
the the edge of the earth to travel too
far but somebody dreamed big somebody
challenged that which was scary at the
time
if you think about it our the boats back
then no we're like they were today and
to get out on a big ocean a long way
away from land and have things go bad
you thought the disease set in it killed
many of the people but somebody still
dreamed of a bigger world a better world
but in order to do that you have to
challenge people and that's what I mean
when I say our colleges and universities
no longer do that and then such a
disservice so the students in here that
are currently in school raise your hand
please I just want to take a look okay a
couple of you I know there's some grads
here as well take notes because there's
gonna be a test after this and it's
gonna be homework okay so if you thought
you we're catching a break coming here
for this conference this weekend I got
bad news for you but for the grads you
folks don't realize maybe you do I
shouldn't say that I don't want to take
it for granted you don't realize how
fortunate you are to be able to attend
this institution eat it up challenge
them soak it all in and when you're done
come away with an attitude that you're
gonna do something good for this world
and too many people and I get asked this
all the time
too many people want to change the world
and I caution them and I say try to
change people everybody you come across
you can make a difference in their lives
that's kind of how I wear this uniform
now I don't try to change the world
every time I meet somebody every time I
get a chance to help somebody
well sometimes the tiniest things you've
made a difference in their life you've
made a difference in their world and
every time you take the opportunity to
do that as you go through life in these
positions that you're going to be in for
the grads and for the students here
you'll change the world but you do one
person at a time
thank you parents go back help the
school thank your teachers everybody
else for providing that pathway for you
to reach your human potential because
that's what education is supposed to be
it's how I looked at it saw my parents
looked at I wasn't the best student
until later on the like didn't go on for
me until I I went out and finished my
undergrad degree in this was indicated
graduated summa [ __ ] laude and my
Master's my graduate program the light
finally went on but at least it did and
I remember how proud my parents were
when I got my master's degree later in
life but my mom always wanted me to have
a master's degree I don't know why but I
told her I would and I remember when I
walked across that stage off Monterey
California and I came off and when the
ceremony was over I went to where my
wife and my my mother and then her
parents were and my mom was in tears
because I told her I would finish one
day that way and I did I wasn't even
thinking about it at the time so that's
why I say make sure you thank
individuals as you move through this
world because they're all trying to help
you they really are some of the ground
rules like I said I came a long way and
a great expense I didn't walk and I'm
not sleeping at a bus shelter so
somebody had to finance getting me and
my wife out here and I want to make it
worth your while
but at the same time you know I don't
come to poke anybody in the eye with a
sharp stick but I don't speak my mind
and sometimes it rubs people the wrong
way I think I'm in pretty good company
here I think but nevertheless I don't
want to paint this broad brush and think
that everybody in here agrees with me
and everybody in here you know has heard
about me and that's not important I'm
just from one school of thought and I
believe in most of the things that we
talk about in this world let's just take
the country all of these issues right
whether it be immigration foreign policy
there's not really a right or wrong but
just schools of thought I just happen to
be from one of those schools of thought
which I can articulate I can tell you
why all right I don't parrot talking
points I don't do well with talking
points as a matter of fact when people
engage me in a conversation and it
starts out or they're just parroting
talking points my first you see me do it
on TV everyone so I don't say look what
the talking points away and let's have a
conversation here all right
I'm just from one school of thought I'm
not right on any of this I don't think
I'm the only one that knows I don't
think I'm the smartest person in the
room I don't need to be I'm just from a
school of thought and I can articulate
why
I have formed my own opinions I have
formed my own positions on these things
and I can back it up doesn't make me
right but I could say - foundation those
are talking points there's no foundation
you heard somebody say that and are you
just repeating and I'm thinking does
this person critically think or do they
just pair a talking points because I
like to have robust debate
I believe in dissent sometimes I think
courage and we hear that a lot
courage I think courage sometimes is
having dissent but that's leadership but
if you don't challenge me from time to
time and I don't do likewise we're never
gonna get over these what do we do about
immigration what do we do about this
economy what do we do because everything
delves into politics and in my
experience once it something hits the
political realm I go well that's over so
if you don't agree with some of the
things that I say that's fine I wasn't
invited here for a debate I was invited
to share some thoughts with you and I'm
going to do that I'm gonna get into it
right now but I just wanted you to know
that and as you watch me in this
national stage which I'm on now I didn't
ask for this but it's a mission now it
really is and sometimes the mission is a
calling I mean when I put this uniform
on for 38 years now this was a mission
to make my community my hometown I'm
from Milwaukee Wisconsin to make it a
better place to be able to serve people
in your hometown to be elected by the
people say we want you in this role in
our representative democracy to
represent our interests now go do it
there's no higher honor
there just isn't there is no higher
honor than aware of the uniform of the
United States and go and defend freedom
there is no higher honor
and every once in a while I like to
challenge people we're having these
discussions and you'll see how yes I get
a little into this how I will all come
together people say sheriff what do we
do about this what do we do about all
this and I say what are you willing to
die for and stops people right in the
tracks what do you want to die for can
you tell me how most people save my kids
right my family things like that a
soldier would tell you my country I
think for the last 38 years I've told
you what I'm willing to die for my
community and in law enforcement you
know we don't get into this to die but
we will if we have to we just want to
know that it's worth it because we're
gonna leave people behind
we're gonna leave friends spouses
children parents my parents is still
with me we're gonna leave them behind
and I've dealt with that stuff the cops
organization concerns of police with
survivors it's a group that they define
as the group you never want to be a part
of you don't ask to join cops cops
organization your spouse or sibling or
someone who's killed in the line of duty
I've worked with those people I've seen
the grief I've seen the pain I've seen
the suffering the people left behind it
hurts for a long time but this
organization wants to know that there's
somebody there that's why I am
intimately involved in it and I watch
and I say to myself sometimes
what must
the people who end up on a memorial wall
by the way how many professions for lack
of a better word have memorials
dedicated to people killed in the line
of duty three cops firefighters and
soldiers that's it
think about that that's what this
country has said how much we value your
service that if you should perish in the
line of duty or overseas fighting for
freedom we're gonna put you on a
memorial wall we're gonna memorialize
you for eternity
think about that in Washington DC at the
law enforcement memorial judiciary
square the names of 20,000 officers who
have been killed in the line of duty
20,000 and as I watch what's happening
to my profession I asked myself a lot
what must they be thinking they died for
this and then you wonder why the cops
across America have stepped back yeah
they have I don't blame them
they got mortgages they got families
they got kids they want to see through
college maybe walk down the aisle they
want to have that all go up in smoke
because it's something that goes
tragically wrong which will in our world
that's what policing is dealing with the
unknown you get a call for service you
don't know when you get there what's
going on and you don't know what's
happening and you don't know how it's
gonna end
but you go
so I sat up here several years ago and
watch this incident unfold in Ferguson
Missouri like many of you and I want
some very powerful people in the United
States trash the reputation the
character the service the integrity the
honor of the American police officer and
I thought wow really when Darren Wilson
defended his life under the rule of law
it allows us to do that big believer in
the rule of law and he had to kill Mike
Brown that's tragic
something went horribly wrong but not
because of Darren Wilson but something
went terribly wrong and I watched people
converge on the unknown city of Ferguson
Missouri I'd be willing to bet
I'd be willing to bet before that
fateful night if I would have given you
a map of Missouri just the outline and
said point to where you think Ferguson
Missouri was I'd be willing to bet less
than 10% of you and that's probably
large wouldn't have been able to even
get close so now all of a sudden these
people converge after this tragic
situation which isn't the first time
it's happened this isn't the first time
a law enforcement officer had to use
deadly force yep and I ask myself why
this time these people were waiting
these cop haters these anarchists they
were waiting for one of these to turn
into a political construct this didn't
happen by chance
and I set up and listened to some very
powerful people trash us and that's what
made this time different than the war on
cops in the 1960s many of you may have
remembered that period of time it was
the same thing was the same people it
was the students for a Democratic
Society anarchists cop haters why do
they go after the cops because we are
the most visible symbol of the rule of
law in your community that's visible
every single day and they go after us to
weaken the police into such a state to
immobilize the police into such a state
of weakness then we no longer have the
nerve to enforce the law that's their
goal all of this other stuff is a
smokescreen all of it the racism
traffics that's all a smokescreen these
anarchists know if they're gonna bring
this country down they have to attack
the rule of law who stands to defend the
rule of law it we're on the front lines
we're not the end of it we're on the
front lines of it weaken us first and
then move on to the next layer we've
seen as I studied the movement what was
different this time
is back in the 60s you didn't have
powerful people chiming in mainly the
political classes that I'm talking about
that's what made this one different it
just got to a point in the days after
Ferguson Missouri in America let's face
in America did not witness its finest
hour the rioting that ensued and I heard
people making excuses for the rioting to
which I replied you have to find a more
socially acceptable way to deal with
your frustration than rioting I heard
the President of the United States say
he understood he understood the rioters
I did I don't know what those businesses
did I don't know what the good
law-abiding people of Ferguson did to
deserve to have their town burned down
and in all these vultures left left the
good people of Ferguson to have to sift
through the ruins and try to put their
lives back together they were gone on to
the next city on to the next incident
this thing grew and now it's this
political construct that I saw coming
two years ago matter of fact I renamed
it coming to a city near you
that was before Baltimore and New York
and Eric garner was tragic situations
but there's a common thread weaving
through all these incidents people tend
to forget about most of these
interactions I said most I'll say 98%
and I'll get to some of the ones that
aren't you had individuals who had no
respect for authority
you had individuals who would not comply
with a law enforcement officers lawful
command you have a duty as a citizen of
the United States you have a duty you
know the duty is to abide by a law
enforcement officers lawful command in
other words they feel the takedown
lights down right the blue and red you
got to pull over
that's complying with the demand you
can't take off when an officer says drop
the weapon or let me see your hand you
have to do it
and when you don't some bad things are
going to happen and when those bad
things happen the people deserve
transparent investigation but I want
these officers judged not by the pleas
of an angry mob
I want these officers judged by the rule
of law what is the rule of law say about
this officers actions not what you think
should happen not what you think should
happen not what you thinks what does the
rule of law say and it's very clear
but that's not the standard anymore it's
political now and in my estimation the
six officers who were charged in the
Freddie gray incident in Baltimore
Maryland their political prisoners
there was no no basis whatsoever under
the rule of law to charge those officers
none so you had a an overactive state's
attorney District Attorney whatever they
call him in in Maryland who was on a
political tour she was gonna try to make
it right for the cop haters
she said when she announced the charging
I hear you your time is now it's not how
I want Lady Justice talking I want Lady
Justice to hold that scale up you've
seen it right we'll weigh the evidence
we'll listen to the witness testimony
and we'll look at all of this and that
will determine what happens that's the
country I want to I want to live in
sometimes we're wrong don't doubt about
it
cops aren't perfect we don't need to be
perfect you know what I tell my people
every day Milwaukee County Sheriff's
Office
I don't demand perfection I demand
excellence and more times than not
that's what I get I said more times than
not I didn't say every time sometimes we
make mistakes the law allows us to make
mistakes
in other words cop pulls somebody over
or goes to Jack somebody up standing on
a corner a group of guys and it's dark
and the officer goes up there thinking
safety first
and he's looking at hands and he's
in all this is all but your training and
experience it's what I want them to rely
on they see some dark object in an alley
or at night and they think it's
something that might be used against
them and they use deadly force and it
turns out to be a cell phone I'm not
saying that it's okay it's called a
mistake that's not a crime in the United
States we have a system to deal with
that it's called tort law you sue the
city you sue the county you sue the
agency because in the United States it's
how we try to make people whole it
doesn't bring them back and it's not
necessarily the best system but that's
how we make people whole in tort law we
give them money we don't charge people
criminally for a mistake so I decided
that I had enough and that if somebody
didn't stand up and start pushing back
on this false narrative that was
starting to take hold about the American
police officer I said this professions
in trouble
and so I took on some pretty powerful
people and let me tell you you don't do
that at the drop of a dime you don't
take on the President of the United
States you don't take on the United
States Department of Justice attorney
general for nothing
these people will power plus those are
respectful positions but so is mine and
so I saw this as a mission and
fortunately for me I had to use uh some
platforms because I don't have my own
platform not yet anyway and with those
platforms I got to spread my message to
start to defend the integrity of people
who put on this uniform on the front
lines and go out near the communities
every day to make it a better place
risk their lives in doing so and they
deserve my support because I send those
men and women out every day not knowing
if they're gonna come back and they
deserve your support as well now I'm at
ground level I'm in the belly of the
beast I still go out on the street I
still make stops it's in my blood tell
people if you cut me I don't bleed red I
bleed blue
and I decided that I was gonna spend the
rest of my time defending this
profession defending those folks who go
out there to make your communities a
better place what I'm talking about when
I say I'm at Ground Zero many of you and
again this might be a false assumption
but I'm going to assume most of you
don't live in the American ghetto yeah I
said get on the left doesn't like that
word you know why because they like to
cleanse the language because they then I
guess it doesn't look so ugly so we
cleansed the language we call it what
economically depressed
we call it central cities no it's a
ghetto and I call it a ghetto for a
reason
riots are not caused by police use of
force riots are caused by the failure of
government riots are caused because
Liberal Democrat politicians in these
urban centers cannot do the hard work or
will not do the hard work of solving
urban pathologies that build up over
time and lead to riots off of something
like a police use of force such as
nothing more to catalyst to a simmering
situation inescapable poverty and the
ghetto massive unemployment in the City
of Milwaukee the city the black
unemployment rate black males 33 percent
the national average for black male
unemployment's 15 so we're nearly three
we're over twice the unemployment rate
so you have men in their prime working
years sitting around idle what are they
gonna do innit sitting around idle part
of the human condition you can find some
way to get by and it's not going to
always be socially acceptable selling
drugs
robbing 7-elevens
another urban pathology crime-ridden
neighborhoods ineffective parenting
fathering kids out of wedlock these are
not necessarily all urban but these are
pathologies that when you stick them all
in one area of the city what do you
think is going to happen so when these
people in the political class can't
solve these problems what do we do we
send the police that's what we do with
all the crime and all the violence
somebody has to go down there and give
the overwhelming majority of good
law-abiding black people some sense of a
peaceful life somebody's got to go down
there and do it so we send the police
officer go down there and keep those
people from killing each other
raping robbing and pillaging the
community and we do we use our training
use our experience to go down there and
do that very tough job because they want
the political class won't do their job
because I always say if you and that's
what we're doing now we're trying to fix
the police and I keep telling people
stop trying to fix the police fix the
damn ghetto
ask yourself why we need so much
assertive policing in the American
ghetto
why does policing work in your community
you're talking about it at the table
over here because in many of your
communities you have what's called
informal social controls informal social
controls keep crime and violence in
check what's an informal social control
effective parenting is an informal
social control those are your kids
you take care of functioning schools are
an informal social control we all know
that kids who are educated are less
likely to engage in some of the
abhorrent behavior that we're seeing
it's an informal social control you have
functioning schools in your community
and your community most people are
employed supporting your family when
you're at work guess what you're not out
doing commit and crying a job is an
informal social control better lifestyle
choices which is what I talk to young
people about all the time everywhere I
go make better lifestyle choices these
things that you're doing today are going
to have a profound effect on you later
on make better lifestyle choices I don't
sit up and talk to young people and
solid life's not fair and you know
racism and it's big better lifestyle
choices nobody held a gun to your head
and told you to join this gang use these
drugs make better lifestyle choices
let's see there's not a lot of effective
parenting and all this stuff coming
together mentoring and leaders to show
the way right role models what we call
Bernie role models only prison in and
out of jail and they see that every day
it becomes part of the landscape but
they think that stuff's normal
so then I come along and I embrace being
a role model in my community and the
left tries to make me the bad guy I'm
the bad guy I say oh really I look and I
say I'm employed been employed for the
last forty five or so years my wife and
I have a home we built that home from
the ground up I have my education I had
a graduate degree like what do you mean
I'm the problem if the worst that
happens to many of these kids you got to
tell this to the left I know I'm
preaching to the choir here but if the
worst that would happen if they looked
at me and said I want to be like that
guy is what he turn out to be a
conservative because that's what they're
really afraid of that's really what
they're afraid of but I think it's a
shame so we send the police in when you
send the police
it is a high-risk proposition I'll tell
you why because we do two things well I
didn't say this is the only thing we do
we do two things well we keep the peace
it for so long that's in our wheelhouse
we do other things that's in our wheels
you need that done call us for all this
other stuff I say don't call us no I'm
serious
I talk about informal social controls
doctor Aaron and I were talking about
that how he can get involved and some
things going on with the kids at school
you don't need the police if you have
effective parenting my mom and dad
didn't need the police when it came to
me
matter of fact sometimes I wish when I
knew when my mom gave me that wait'll
your dad comes home I was hoping the
police would arrive first and don't get
me wrong you know my dad didn't beat me
unnecessarily with just the fear that
look the fear was enough that's why all
my mom had to say was Whittle your dad
guitar that's all she had to say that's
all she had to say effective parenting
you folks know about it but I'll tell
you right now in the ghetto it is in
short supply so you send the police
remember we keep the peace we enforce
the law if there's a violation of the
law we have to take action and we can do
any number of things right but I'll tell
you right now if it comes down to giving
a lawful command and it's not followed
we can't walk away i watch this stuff
going on in schools you've seen some of
the incidents with law enforcement
officers in school and first of all I
tell people when they say oh look at
digit first of all I said something
happened to cause that off so I'm making
excuses somebody didn't comply with a
law enforcement officers lawful command
young lady you got to leave the
classroom first of all the teacher told
her to leave the classroom she effed the
teacher right teacher calls the
principal principal comes in young lady
you have to she asks the principal call
the cops you man when I said when you
call the cops high risk you can't F the
police we can't walk away the teacher
walked away well I can't you won't
listen to me the principal else you
won't listen to me the cop can't say
that's what I would have done thought of
coppice it just didn't she won't listen
to me you handle it there's no violation
of the law here that's what we doing is
sitting in the desk and walk away but we
don't get to do that first of all I
think it's a sad day to have police
officers at school one of the first
things I did is sheriff I took him out I
took my deputies out of schools I said
they don't belong it's not our it's not
one of our core functions and don't give
me this well hey you know cops can
establish relationship we forget about
that when I was a school day away you
know you know who the teachers relying
on mom and dad not the cops but we think
it's the neat things put the cops in
school it's not a neat thing you put
these cops in these situations and they
use force and I'm not making excuses for
it but some of the incidents that I saw
I said wait a minute
he had to use force his lawful command
was not adhered to he had to use force
but here's we have to judge now on its
reasonableness not could he have done
something else it's not what the law
says the law says we judge officers
actions on reasonableness did what he is
what he did under those circumstances
reasonable under the circumstances not
what you would have done not what you
would have done because I heard people I
would have did I said but you didn't get
called we did and was it reasonable and
here's another thing about force it's
never pretty it's not designed to be
pretty it's designed to be effective and
we teach our officers reasonably to end
these confrontations quickly why so they
don't end up like Darren Wilson and Mike
Brown doesn't end up in having to use
deadly force so you end it quickly you
decentralize you see a cop taking
somebody down to the ground I heard it
the other day referred to as body slam
no we teach officers to decentralise get
them on the ground or get him up against
the wall
so you may can maintain control now I
don't expect you folks to agree with or
understand that but the training is all
certified by the state the way we train
our officers sometimes officers will do
something they shouldn't do well then
that's my job
I sent a sergeant one of my sergeants to
prison five years ago why for beating a
handcuffed prisoner in the back of a
squad car I'm not putting up with that
nonsense we're better than that let's
see that's my job and I'm elected by the
way the people in Waukee County want me
making these decisions and if I start
making decisions that they're not happy
with they'll get rid of me don't get rid
of me real fast at the election at the
ballot box but as a law enforcement
professional as an executive I could to
be one of the judges or arbiters of that
action which is why they call me all the
time on TV what do you think about this
and I use my experience having done that
having done it I've been there and I
know how these things can spiral out of
control in a hurry if you don't end it
quickly like I said it's not supposed to
be pretty and everyone thought did you
see a nice it's not supposed to be
pretty it's supposed to be effective and
reasonable and the cops get out of line
we have a process to deal with that but
here's what I don't want I don't want
somebody who has never done this job
what's not for one day in their life
done it I don't want them telling us how
we should be doing this folks that'd be
like me trying to transform the medical
community I've no no nothing about
medical science I've never done that a
day in my life and I'm gonna come in and
say well the doctor should have done
this and how come the nurse didn't
talking about I need to let the medical
community figure that out
President Obama needs to let the law
enforcement community and at the local
level figure this out and just because
some cops go to the dark side and they
do some things that yeah Walter Scott
South Carolina ugly I said it on TV
I said I was appalled by that and I was
as I've never seen that in my life but I
know the difference between good
policing and bad policing and he was
charged with a felony and you'll pay for
that but because of these aberrations
and that's what that is that is an
aberration we want to change an entire
profession because of an aberration do
you know how dangerous that is because
these people have not thought through
the law of unintended consequences by
trying to change this profession it's
going to have a profound impact on good
law-abiding people you'll pays the
highest toll when you declare war on
police officers good law-abiding
minorities and the ghetto pay the
highest price the president knows that
Eric Holder knows that and then you want
to tell me that black lives matter oh
yeah as far as I'm concerned it's a
group of people who truly care about the
lives of other black people the police
officers will go down in these
communities every day to serve and
protect them
that's who really cares about black
lives
and if black lives truly mattered to
these had to catch myself there if black
lives truly mattered to these imbeciles
they would be right now 24/7 protesting
in the city of Chicago we're in the
first three months of the year overall
150 people have been murdered mainly
black 84 percent increase over last
year's first three months and last year
was bad and over 800 people have been
shot in the city of Chicago ladies and
gentlemen those sound like casualties
after an armed conflict over in the
Middle East 150 dead 800 wounded
it sounds like a fierce firefight
doesn't it and here it's happening in
the great city of Chicago one weekend
not too long ago 37 dead and a weekend
same with Baltimore after the Freddie
gray or the police backed off Memorial
Day weekend 37 people murdered and what
do we do we kind of oh that's terrible
oh that's it well if it's so terrible
then lay off the police because the
police are the last line of defense down
there for many of these folks and then
like I'm gonna say it again the
overwhelming majority of people down
there are good law-abiding people they
gotta be defended and it's only the cop
that's doing it's not the politician
doing it it's not the cop hater doing it
it's not the anarchist doing it it's not
blacklivesmatter doing it it's the
American police officer and if we want
order restored to these cities where
crime has taken a steep spike if we one
ordered restored if we really care about
these folks
then get behind me and get these people
to back off the American police officer
don't go back to work here's what's
happening your best policing its self
initiated policing it's not answering
the 9-1-1 call
if 911s to be called usually it's over
right
the incident already occurred got my
house broken into my car stolen someone
stuck a gun in my face and took my walk
it's over your best policing itself
initiating self initiated policing where
that cop goes in and he or she develops
the reasonable suspicion because I
believe in this Constitution and the
rule of law we have to have reasonable
suspicion to stop somebody and they look
and they develop that reasonable
suspicion hey look at that car over
there and by the way it's got expired
plates there's your reasonable suspicion
to pull it over the courts have already
ruled the subjective intent of the
officer they said does not matter they
say was to stop legal yes he had expired
plates now you might say well that's
just a small thing no it's not and I'll
tell you what you're gonna find what
self-initiated policing when you make
these stops you're gonna find people
wanted on serious felony warrants that
you can take to jail get them off the
street you're gonna find weapons
possessed illegally that might be on the
way to or war involved or away from some
sort of armed robbery or shooting and
you can do the ballistics tests and all
of that you're gonna find illegal drugs
it is a treasure chest of criminal
activity self-initiated no one sent the
cop over to pull that car over no one
sent the cop over because those jamokes
were hanging out on the corner and the
neighbors are calling in saying police
get those drug dealers off my corner and
we go and do it and we're the bad guy
according the black lives matter well
there's not any real self-initiated
policing going on right now we can't
make cops to self-initiative police
only make them go to the 9-1-1 calls so
when people say the cops are doing this
on pertaineth or not you can't blame
them they don't want to be the next
Darren Wilson well by the way it was
cleared under the rule of law and I
remind people all the time too you're
entitled of due process in the United
States of America you are not entitled
to an outcome you may not like what the
grand jury did in New York with Eric
garner I had some problems with it but
for a different reason I wouldn't have
sent the cops there to begin with for
selling loosies cigarettes I would have
said tell him to send the State
Department of Revenue over there why do
we have cops doing tax collection work
you see what I mean when I say we get
them out of there you know what they're
really good at and what they're trained
to do we have them now performing tax
collection work we're cops we're not tax
collectors if you don't you send the cop
where I said lot can go wrong in a hurry
they had to take care of Gardner jail
Eric garner said I'm not going to jail
oh yes he was going to jail and how do
you just put his hands behind his back
like the officer said you heard the
audio turn around put your hands behind
your back if he'd had done that Eric
garner be like today but when they don't
put their hands behind their back you
have to use force and then everybody
wants to get real technical well why
didn't they do this doesn't work like
that in our world guys going to jail not
have to be reasonable right I can't pick
him up by his ankles and start pounding
that's not reasonable but you all know
what reasonable looks like and then let
the rule of law do its work and more
times than not we're gonna get the
benefit of the doubt people want to know
why if the cops always exonerated
because of the rule of life we don't
like it then we should change the rule
of law you don't go after the cop for
criminal prosecution so this is what
we're up against
these this is we're gonna win this we
won it in the 60s the war on cops we
want it it's gonna take some time but
somebody's got to be out there defending
the American police officer I'm doing
what I can I'll do the heavy lifting I
just need you folks to cover my flanks
and once again sneak attacks and lay on
your political leaders to back off these
people the cops
as Thomas Sol said I met Thomas Sol
recently one of the highlights of my
career a guy I read a lot of his works
he and I had been communicating by email
and finally I went out to see him Thomas
Sol says they're real simple if you're
going to have law you must have law
enforcement that's us otherwise you
don't have long so I want to close with
just a couple things here for you to go
away with just to keep in mind
this is good many of you are at that age
you remember Peter Falk Columbo you can
just see him saying this now let me see
if I have this right the family
situation is so unstable jr. doesn't
even know where to send a Father's Day
card there's no guidance or discipline
in the home Jr gets dumped in the
education system where he is socially
promoted because the overwhelm School
District can't deal with the
undisciplined whelp juniors major
formative influence our gangster rap
videos and a corresponding peer group of
gangsta wannabes at age 18 Junior is
turned loose on society carrying a bad
attitude a broken compass and little
respect for authority Junior gets
himself in a big trouble trouble with
the law and meets with dire consequences
then the situational diagnosis is that
the police need more training and
understanding pardon me for asking but
do you really believe that [ __ ]
that's the heart of it you've all seen
that
you're a president of the United States
draping himselves with a couple of law
enforcement lackeys and coming up with
this 21st century task force to
transform this profession and like I
said he's never done this work a day in
his life I don't want him transforming
this profession we have policing in
America right it's not perfect it can't
be because it involves human beings and
human beings aren't perfect we get it
right and we're not as corrupt as some
nation's police forces all right we
better be real careful and letting
people totally turn this profession
upside down on its on its head because
of an aberration like laQuan McDonald in
Chicago I see teachers now that are
being charged with having inappropriate
sex with their students I haven't heard
anybody say that we need to transform
the profession of teaching no we deal
with those bad teachers that's a last
one was for another day Baltimore
Maryland can you imagine what the cops
must have been feeling after watching
that in real-time their cruiser we live
in those cars we work in those cars they
afford us protection there are offices
right starters
people like to paint cops with this
broad brush they're all racists right
anarchists don't be fooled by these
they're not protesters by the way this
is insurrection that's what I said
recently on TV and I hear these things
black lives matter the only people will
really believe that our American police
officers who go into the American
ghettos every day to keep people from
killing each other when you see the
black on black homicide that happens on
a very frequent basis we don't see
protests we don't see marches and we
don't see demands for change their black
lives if they really mattered that's
where the outrage would be that's where
we see the protest and like I said these
people are nowhere to be found
I'm proud of these guys I say guys no
truly proud of these men and women that
come in here every day under these
difficult circumstances even before now
it was still a difficult job it's just
been made more difficult no respect for
authority again anarchists and we're
supposed to want to sit down and what
have a discussion with these folks you
got to be kidding more dialogue the
president says with these with these
people the misuse of data and statistics
about police officer used to force when
it comes to blackmail you know what the
narrative is right now well you know we
killed law enforcement officers are
quick to use force on black males and
it's just not true there's no data or
research and I've read it all there's no
data research that support this here's
one report dr. Timothy Johnson notice in
the right hand corner there I I always
cite this stuff where I got it from by
two-to-one margin more white males are
killed in police interactions and black
males where's all the screaming from the
white males
they might have a claim but yet we hear
the opposite meant to be humorous but
it's not Eric Holder with his anti
police rhetoric and hears about this guy
on the right was killed last week police
use of force in the city of Chicago and
it resulted in black lives matter
converging on a city of Chicago last
week took over a part of the interstate
system for this guy this guy's mom after
he was shot and killed the guy on the
right and you know what I get moms I
just do you love your children no matter
what I get that but she stood up there
and said my child didn't have to be shot
like that he was a good kid look at him
I'm not blaming her I'm saying black
lives matter gathered for this killing
last week yet last summer nine-year-old
Tyshawn Lee black kid nine years old was
lured out into an alley and shot and
killed by his dad's rival gang member
there were no protests by black lives
matter when Tyshawn Lee at nine years
old
was gunned down and they're gonna rally
for this guy
we're scraping the bottom of the barrel
folks I'm not saying this guy deserved
to die but he they it's alleged and
trust me that's the word you have to use
he pointed a handgun at a Chicago police
officer tolling the drop and he wouldn't
a police officer shot him they recovered
the gun at the scene it probably
happened and his mom said he didn't have
to die to which my response wasn't and
not to be mean but you gotta stop these
false why are we embracing this as he's
a good kid he's not a good kid look at
him we can't we have to stop embracing
this stop that's what I meant I meant to
be mean to her but I said maybe if you'd
have done a better job of parenting he
might not have turned out that way I
said Mike you can't we cannot I'm not
gonna allow people to embrace it he's a
good kid look at him this guy is
stone-cold gangster you're not a good
kid things were not going to end up
right at some point in this guy's life
maybe another rival gang member or shot
in a drug deal he wasn't gonna live that
long the leading cause of death
black males under 25 homicide you know
what it is for other demographics under
25 leading cause of death white males
accidents homicide ladies and gentlemen
leading cause of death lifestyle choices
remember what I said
I tell young people make better lives he
made a lifestyle choice he chose thug
life
he made that and then I hear all this
stuff about how the cops got to do a
better job of improving their
relationship with the community it's a
lie no we don't here's a Rasmussen poll
nobody would accuse Rasmussen of being
this Pro cop group right so they did a
survey this came out two weeks ago what
America thinks good cop bad cop there's
a war on police in America nearly 60% of
people agree with that that were polled
crime in urban areas is a great
problems in police discrimination 70% of
those polled said yeah crimes a bigger
problem
political comments critical of police
are increasing the danger 60% of those
polled said yeah this war on cops is
hurting and here's my favorite police
performance good or excellent 72 percent
of those polls said yeah we like our
police it's not perfect soon we're near
a hundred right show me somebody else
who has numbers approval numbers like
that but there's a fourth nerve of a
narrative out that it's dominating and
then people say well the police have to
change that's not what these folks are
saying they're saying that ghetto has to
change and then there's another 131
mayor's across the country from last
year surveyed wanted to know how they
rate their Police Department's
relationship with minority communities
and mayor's no right I had those two top
figures together 78 percent of these 31
mayors across the country said their
police departments relationship with
minority communities as excellent or
good why are we hearing this false
narrative cops are racist and hate black
people
the mayor's don't think so and so we
should train change this profession for
that bottom line they're 10% of these of
those mayor's polled here said it's poor
you don't change an entire industry or
profession because of that
that's called an outlier on the bottom
you disregard that when I talk about the
rules that the statistics that get
ignored and the manipulation of data
that's called an outlier you throw it
out we're gonna change the profession
because 78 percent he's mayor said it's
pretty good with minority committed said
white community minority community that
means these mayor's had to have minority
communities in their city to even answer
that question so don't think they got
these from all these suburban areas
because they don't have minority
communities so that's the false
narrative that I'm going to continue
you to push back against until we win
this war on cops
and we're gonna win it ladies and
gentlemen we have to for the survival of
America I don't know how I how I did on
time I don't worry about that I was told
about 40 minutes or sewing 15 minutes
for Q&A and the way I looked at it I
said I got 55 minutes all the portion of
the way I want to run and I've been
doing this long enough that I've learned
a thing or two and the less time you
leave for questions or less trouble you
can get into but no I wanted to give you
your money's worth and if we don't get
the questions it's fine it's just the
way it goes
hang in there folks okay I know these
are some very precarious times that
we're living in but I believe in the
resilience of America I really do this
country's been through a lot I've been
through a revolution went through a
constitutional convention or the United
States Constitution almost didn't pass
ratification by the states you know
about the Federalist paper Federalist
Papers in a role that played trying to
convince some of these states to go
along with the Constitution Constitution
wasn't perfect but it got it right all
right my ancestors weren't included in
the Constitution we weren't considered
people we were considered property but
guess what
because I still believe in the
brilliance of that document they put a
mechanism in there to eventually get it
right we can amend the Constitution and
we did don't forget the United States
Supreme Court did not end slavery the
Thirteenth Amendment to the Constitution
and it's later
and the 14th amendment insisted that the
states allow the entire Constitution to
apply to my ancestors that's the
brilliance of that document we can
change it we can get it right we've been
through a civil war can you imagine
living at that time thinking this nation
was going to survive probably thinking
of a lot of what I hear today I don't
know how we're gonna do it and I believe
in the resilience of this country we
survived a civil war America came out
stronger and better right we survived
two world wars two world wars
this country we survived the turbulent
60s we thought it was falling apart and
then we'd never get it back on track and
we did we always come out better we
survived 9/11 we survived a Great
Depression think of this we have a
tendency as humans to to only look
recently to use as a basis for you know
we're ever going to get out of this
we're ever gonna it's a resilient
country it's a resilient country because
of its people not it's a political class
not its government because of its people
as long as we don't give up well bones
facts was ladies and gentlemen
Timmy Carter
so we will survive Barack Obama ladies
and gentlemen god bless you thank you so
much and may God continue to bless the
United States of America